we are in the house of
our guests
Bakhmut, they destroyed
and did not capture a part of the outskirts of Bakhmut -
this is all the rezon and
part of the surroundings, this is the road that goes to
Constantinivka on the outskirts of Bakhmut, at that
time, now there are battles, every city, every
settlement, which is now located
in the temporarily occupied territory, of course,
in the plans in  there are plans to release them. But
for now, Bakhmut should not be stormed or
cleared, but bypassed from the flanks, closed,
blocked, and only after that,
it is more expedient to carry out the clearing, which, in principle, is
being done now